since director and EMU Scotties it
floated into theaters in September of
2017 horror movie fans the world over
have learned everything there is to know
about the film but something fans may
not know is the real reason why the
original director of it's Emmy Award
winner Cary Fukunaga left the project
chatting with GQ in a recent interview
Fukunaga discussed the true motivation
behind his decision to step away from it
after developing the film for three
years the filmmaker who also wrote the
script for his adaptation of the Stephen
King classic explained that Warner
Brothers brass were worried he might
start behaving erratically well that he
wouldn't work well with others to this
day a fuga NACA still doesn't understand
why the studio began treating him
differently just two weeks ahead of when
his version of it was meant to get
behind the cameras he told GQ I think it
was fear on their part that they
couldn't control me they thought they
couldn't control me he continued adding
that the studio executives were
completely wrong to assume the worst
about him as he's never been one to go
off the rails when directing Fukunaga
went on to explain I would have been a
total collaborator that was the kind of
ridiculous part it was just more of a
perception I have never seen a note and
been like you guys no way it's always
been a conversation getting Candide
Fukunaga later admitted that he does
quote have a tendency to make things
harder than they need to be but even
then Fukunaga doesn't believe himself to
be difficult stubborn or uncooperative
Fukunaga brought up his fourth feature
film beasts of no nation as an example
saying I don't think I've ever been able
to make something and compromising like
someone commented on beasts oh how did
it feel to make a movie that's
uncompromising like uncompromising I had
to rewrite my entire third act because
we didn't have the money to finish the
film we compromised all over the place
Fukunaga z' names first attached to it
in 2012 in june of that year The
Hollywood Reporter confirmed that the
adaptation would be split into two parts
and that Fukunaga had climbed aboard the
project as director and a co-writer
alongside chase Palmer
when 2014 rolled around it had moved to
Warner Brothers New Line Cinema division
and producer Dan Lynn revealed that
Fukunaga would only direct the first
film in the two-part feature of that
time Lynn also told vulture that its
author Stephen King gave the team his
blessing indicating that things were
going swimmingly behind the scenes
Lynne said we didn't want to make this
unless he felt it was the right way to
go and when we sent King the script the
response that Kari got back was go with
God please this is the version the
studio should make so that was really
gratifying the project continued
smoothly with Fukunaga Lynne and Palmer
later tapping The Maze Runner franchise
star will Poulter to play penny wise the
demonic entity bill skarsgård wound up
playing a moose Quixote's film georgie
meet penny wise but just three weeks
after word of Poulter's casting when
public and early May of 2015
Fukunaga exited air on May 25th 2015 The
Wrap reported the Fukunaga repeatedly
clashed with the studio and did not want
to compromise his artistic vision in the
wake of budget cuts that were recently
demanded by new line which greenlit the
first film at 30 million dollars a few
months later
Fukunaga opened up about the situation
explaining in a statement obtained by
variety that he was trying to make an
unconventional horror film that didn't
fit into the algorithm of what Warner
Brothers could spend to make it and what
the studio would earn back once the film
was released according to Fukunaga in
the first movie what I was trying to do
was an elevated horror film with actual
characters they didn't want any
characters they wanted archetypes and
scares I wrote the scripts they wanted
me to make a much more inoffensive
conventional script but I don't think
you can do proper Stephen King and make
it an offensive every little thing was
being rejected and us for changes our
conversations weren't dramatic it was
just quietly acrimonious we didn't want
to make the same movie it wasn't long
after Fukunaga stew Parcher that Warner
Brothers hired mama filmmaker and EMU
Scotty to take his place
the film went on to earn over 700
million dollars against its reported
thirty-five million dollars production
budget when it debuted on September 8
2017 five years and critics and fans
alike agreed that it had the F factor to
become one of the best films of 2017
while Fukunaga never got to realize his
dream of adapting it for the silver
screen
he hasn't been down on his luck or
without work in the time since in 2018
at TNT rolled out the alienist the 10
episode period drama series the Fukunaga
wrote and executive produced
he's also been hard at work on Netflix
as maniac a dark comedy miniseries
starring Jonah Hill and Emma Stone
sounds like he's still floating just
fine well vote Downey
[Music]